à partir de demain à montréal va
accueillir la compétition de gymnastique
la plus importante de l'année au pays
c'est l'international gymnix qui réunit
les meilleurs gymnastes du monde au
complexe sportif claude-robillard tu as
une belle occasion de sortir pour les
étudiants qui sont les écoliers en
semaine de relâche zoé est allé à bouger
bourgi nous menons est avec nous bougies
j'ai changé votre nom à cause de
brigitte bon voilà qui travaillent avec
nous bonjour je vous l ai participé vous
êtes la porte-parole de cet événement là
est ce que ces spas première fois que
vous participez à cet événement là non
ça représente quoi sur le calendrier
c'est une compétition et arsenal que
nous on accueille notre club
donc le fief du ministre on accueille
cette compétition l'heure il ya plein de
pays qui vont lire compétionner pour
essayer de la première phase et moi en
tant que porte-parole d'être là pour
supporter l'événement puis encouragé mes
amis à la commission bon il ya des
athlètes de 15 pays qui vont revenir à
montréal pour cet événement là c'est
assez particulier parce que c'est une
année olympique à l'international gymnix
ça permet pas de gagner des points pour
le classement mondial mais c'est
vraiment là où les entraîneurs des
équipes canadiennes vont pouvoir monter
l'équipe qui pourrait aller à tokyo
en fait ces conflits sont là ça veut
juste servir aux membres de l'équipe
nationale de su prouver encore une fois
une compétition nationale et de findus
corde pour que les gens qui s'occupent
de l'équipe nationale qui est qui
s'occupe de la formation de l'équipe
olympique puisse regarder le cisco
l'appui voir qu'elle joue là ce pourrait
alors il ya combien de l'athlète
canadienne qui pourrait faire partie de
cette équipe olympique qui on doit
surveiller à ce que des noms des
athlètes en particulier qu'on doit
surveiller donc l'équipe et que ça va
être quatre gymnastes et une substitut
et après on peut ici d'aller chercher
deux autres places supplémentaires en
commande ou au cinépalmes qui vont être
en mai et les accès de regarder danser
gymnix il y aura les deux défis qui ont
été dans l'équipe des jeux olympiques de
2016 dont il rosoux puis ils avaient
leurs discours et sinon ils auraient
rousseau et victoria ou qui vont être
sur place aussi donc c'est qu'a fait le
très forte et il va bien vous êtes
spécialiste des bars et sa mort l'apôtre
aussi ben oui évidemment vous situez
vous dans cet essai cette sélection
canadienne est ce que est ce que les
jeux de tokyo serait passé pour vous
cette année donc les juste réussi mon
but post année donc je préparais à faire
des compétitions j'en ai normalement
début avril
donc je mets rentrer mes énergies pour
essayer de bien performer au cours de
l'année puis espérer avoir une place
heures et l'équipe parce que là il ya
vous il ya d'autres qui vont essayer
d'obtenir cette place pour elle est là
est ce qu'il ya des d'autres pays qui
profitent également de la compétition
peut-être pour finaliser leur équipe
parce que ce que ça vous donne une idée
c'est un tremplin important pour tokyo
soit pour toutes les gymnastes sont là
c'est en coupe et son utilisateur peut
venir se pratiquer sur le podium et
c'est une grosse salle beaucoup de
spectateurs donc les jeunes assez sûr
qu'ils vont du plaisir à venir
la compétition qui lie pays envoient
leurs équipes pour richard prasquier
puis donner une expérience alors je
n'associe et mine de rien l'équipe
canadienne elle est montante le faut le
dire depuis quelques années c'est une
équipe à surveiller
il faut absolument parler du coronavirus
ça bouscule le calendrier sportif
partout sur la planète
est ce que ça a changé quelque chose
dans les terres de saidal gymnix donc
aller dans ce sens je lis encore lu mais
depuis qu'ils ont annulé leur présence
donc la roumanie et le japon vont pas
être là mais la compétition quand même
avant lui qui ont melilli les moyens
c'est ça pour que tout soit propre piqué
en satin bienvenus mais ce qu'ils
aimaient la compétition lors des des
mesures particulières ce que vous allez
faire de l'apôtre avec un masque non
mais peut-être savoir si jamais ça
pouvait donner de noms mais c'est à voir
parce qu'il ya le cio également qui se
réunit aujourd'hui pour se pencher là
dessus et voir si ça ça a des
conséquences mais à part les deux
équipes c'est dommage que les romains de
c'est toujours une bonne équipe ça ce
serait une bonne rivalité des voix
refaire et déboires travailler sur
sur les différents plateaux réputé on
vous souhaite une bonne une bonne
semaine ça commence donc demain pour le
restant de fait jamais d'apporter de
vendredi si le club peut aussi les
conditions essentielles mais sinon en
force et de demain ici les combis son
instinct et si c'était potelets c'est
juste les femmes qui sont là bas deux
hommes à cet événement là mais ça vaut
le déplacement ça va être certainement
très spectaculaire merci beaucoup aux
week-ends